when he started saying your head is like
a watermelon were you hoping he would
pick a different fruit or vegetable you
know he went from calling me a pencil
neck to a watermelon head and let me
just say a watermelon head on a pencil
neck is a pretty tough balance yes it is
but my my predominant uh thought on the
uh on the various nicknames was you know
I thought he was better at it than that
uh the whole you know cardinal rule of
nicknames is you pick one and you stick
to it yes uh and he's had about eight of
them for me over the years and uh and so
I I don't think they've been as
effective as they could be uh if he just
stuck to